te has preguntado
qué harías si no tuvieras miedo
hace unos años hice un viaje que no
planee nada bien en mi primer día en
chile- llamada quedado sin dinero sin
comida y sin teléfono además no conocí a
nadie en esa ciudad después de casi 16
horas de no tener nada en el estómago lo
mejor que se me pudo ocurrir en ese
momento fue ir al centro comercial que
estuviera más cerca
y poder encontrar que comprar de comer
con solamente 500 pesos pero no es lo
que estás pensando 500 pesos en méxico
son como 12 pesos nada más y después de
mucho tiempo de estar dándole vueltas al
centro comercial lo único que terminó
por encontrar fue más hambre pero justo
antes de entrar a una tienda de repente
alguien se me acerca y me dice hola yo
hoy en jugar un bañito
tipo gallito
en citas si si jugamos
lo que pasa es que tengo que hacer algo
importante y reseñable una tienda y no
hay problema pues nos vemos por allá ok
yo
entonces me metí a la tienda obviamente
no me alcanzado para nada salgo pensando
en quién era yo si va a ser cuando me
acuerdo este tipo rápido me escondí
detrás de una columna y me fijé a ver si
de verdad estaba esperándome
y estaba esperando
obviamente en seguir pero me ganó más la
curiosidad y me acerque resulta que esta
persona de verdad quería jugar gallitos
bueno en citas es más jugamos dos de
tres rondas y eso quiero mucho más de lo
que yo qué crees las dos me gano también
después de la humillación que me paro de
la nada otra vez me pregunta hoy es tal
y como está ahí con dios
no no de verdad
como esta y se acerca a su mochila saca
tremenda biblia la pone en la mesa y
empezamos a hablar de dios por un rato o
te y no fue hasta que los crujidos en mi
estómago me hicieron ver la hora que
eligió oye todo aquí fue ahí cuando las
cosas estaban al siguiente nivel
en ese momento el hombre se ofreció a
mostrarme la ciudad en su carro
inmediatamente escuché la voz de mi
amada diciendo la lección que a todos
nos enseñan de pequeños y nunca te vayas
a ir con ningún desconocido por favor
esta historia terminar conmigo
pero
junto con otro extraño que subió en el
camino de no ser
que decidí confiar en un desconocido te
juro que ese día no comía no hubiera
conocido una persona increíble y nunca
hubiera aprendido en mi primer día en
chile que decir weon es como decir wave
que al agua cartel edición alta y que a
veces cuando estás diciendo la palabra
ya estás diciendo que sí
pero te tengo que confesar algo
yo no fui el único que corrió un riesgo
ese día los mexicanos en latinoamérica
no tenemos la mejor reputación que
digamos si somos justos
daniel también decidió jugársela me
salvó el día y no lo volví a ver jamás
para mí no hay mejor palabra que pueda
describir a daniel que como un héroe
ya hay algo en los héroes como el que
siempre me ha llamado la atención si tú
le preguntabas es más si tuve
preguntabas de chiquito que quería ser
de grande entre otras cosas yo te decía
que quería ser un héroe
específicamente te decía que quería ser
es player band
pero es más imagínate
tan fanático era de spider-man no me lo
vas a creer en una cartita al niño dios
le pedí que me concedieran los poderes
y como que el niño dios
otro concepto de spider-man
bueno pero fuera de broma y volviendo al
punto
deberías hacer lo mismo que danielle
no sólo jugaría sencillitas con un
extraño en un centro comercial y lo
llevarías paseando por toda la ciudad en
tu auto también te invitaría de comer le
prestarías tu celular
hasta lo llevarías contigo el trabajo
de verdad
los días
y por qué no
a ver ya sé lo que estás pensando es que
esteban la inseguridad aquí en méxico
está muy difícil
créeme entiendo
lo que te voy a decir
no tiene una manera agradable de
contados
secuestraron a mi papá cuando tenía 16
años y nunca
supimos que no son los responsables
aún más cuando las autoridades te dicen
que en esos casos los causantes suelen
ser personas conocidas
como no sales a la calle con miedo
pero algo que mitigó para toda la vida y
lo aprendí de haber ido a terapia
es que en realidad solamente existen dos
tipos de miedo
el miedo de supervivencia que casi sin
pensar y por instinto nos hace actuar
y el miedo a lo desconocido
que muy sigilosamente parece que te
cuida pero muchas veces te altos a
voltea nada más poniendo excusas por
ejemplo aquel día en que secuestraron a
mi papá recuerdo que nos dijeron que en
medio de los forcejeos su teléfono cayó
al piso una persona lo recogió y para
intentar devolver lo logró comunicarse
con alguien cercano a nosotros para
cuando esta persona por fin entabló
conversación con mi mamá le dijo
perdóneme señora
habíamos muchos y nadie visual
ya piensas que tú en la misma situación
que esas personas
tampoco áreas salvo
pero pregúntate y si la persona a la que
estuvieran secuestrando es alguien de tu
familia no harías nada
siendo brutalmente honestos la
diferencia entre porque dependiendo de
las circunstancias
actuamos o ponemos excusas
no es el miedo porque en ambos casos el
miedo existe
el problema y la razón del por qué quizá
no harías lo mismo que daniel pero
seguramente si harías lo mismo que las
personas presentes en el secuestro en el
papá es porque lo desconocido
no te importa lo suficiente
y después de vivir esta situación tan
complicada
imaginas tener a tu papá secuestrado
me dije a mí mismo que tenía que hacer
algo al respecto era que la gente dejara
de secuestrar y que en las calles la
gente fuera más solidaria me dije bah
quiero cambiar el mundo y lo voy a hacer
solamente hace falta tomar al toro por
los cuernos no
la realidad es que mi toro ni cuernos
y me explico por qué en mi intento por
cambiar el mundo terminé por estudiar
pedagogía e innovación educativa y es
que no sé si te ha pasado pero en cada
conversación que yo tenía con las
personas acerca de los problemas del
país llegábamos a una misma conclusión
si mejoramos la educación en nuestro
país
podríamos crear una sociedad más justa y
así habría menos inseguridad no sería su
increíble
hasta pensar pues es que si tanta gente
diferente llega a la misma idea
seguramente es verdad
pero después de estudiar toda una
carrera de innovación educativa estar
trabajando en el sector durante un
tiempo y pasar cuando me di cuenta de
que la idea donde la educación lo
resuelve todo
no solo es equivocada
es hasta irresponsable
pero no no me malinterpretes en la
educación si es importante
pero la tradicional como la conocemos o
sea las escuelas por sí solas
no son la solución y cómo van a hacerlo
solamente se a tapar el sol con un dedo
porque actualmente sabemos mucho
y nos entendemos muy poco
hay más información que nunca
pero también más confusión cada vez hay
más gente con algún nivel académico
y sin oportunidades para el futuro
el juke es irresponsable pensar que la
educación es la respuesta para todos
nuestros problemas porque solamente le
estás quitando un peso a las otras áreas
importantes de la sociedad
tú en tu familia y en tu trabajo eres
igual de responsable que cualquier
escuela de intentar crear un futuro
mejor pero así como las personas
presentes en el supuesto de mi papá
te detiene un supuesto miedo de ir más
allá lo que te corresponde por algo que
no conoces y ni siquiera me refiero de
intentar un acto heroico
simplemente de salir de tu burbuja
piénsalo cuando se trata de un problema
desconocido
basta con cualquier excusa que te haga
sentir bien para solamente hacer el
mínimo o como nos gusta decirle para
solamente hacer lo que me corresponde
intenta recordar
cuando fue la última vez
existe más de lo que te correspondía
la verdad es que no intento el día de
hoy convencerte de que si te toca
presenciar un secuestro pues arriesgues
tu vida ni tampoco hay que si conoces a
una persona en el centro comercial pues
una vez raid por toda la ciudad verdad
aunque sí creo que todos podríamos
aprender algo de aquí el chileno
ese día cuando daniel un completo
extraño
dijo oye jugaba
nuevamente si lo juzgue cuando miro como
está ahí con dios pues todavía más
pero si daniel nunca se hubiera atrevido
a preocuparse
preocuparse por un desconocido
nunca hubiéramos aprendido todo lo que
tenemos en común resulta que danielle es
un chileno que le fascina méxico o como
él lo llamaría y méxico lindo y querido
también resulta que daniel es un
arquitecto que trabaja diseñando
escuelas innovadoras y que dedicaban la
mitad de sus semanas a labores
misioneras
eso explica la biblia y su pregunta de
dios no
danielle y son mucho más de lo que le
correspondía y lo que aprendí no fue
hacer el bien sin mirar a quién es
porque ayudar sin involucrarte
no es ayudar
para de verdad cambiar el mundo
no necesitamos labores altruistas
independientes
necesitamos que vayamos más allá de
nuestras burbujas familiares y de
trabajo y empecemos a preocuparnos por
aquello que supuestamente no me
corresponde los problemas desconocidos
y te cambio la pregunta que dice al
inicio en vez de preguntarte
qué harías si no tuvieras miedo
pregúntate qué harías
aunque estuvieras miedo porque yo no
quiero en un futuro como mucha gente
dice de vive sin miedo no yo creo en un
futuro donde todos somos unos miedosos
pero nadie es indiferente
si tú ya no quiere seguir siendo
indiferente te quiero invitar a los
siguientes
primero a que identifiques si hoy tú
está secuestrada
pero con una idea en una burbuja donde
solo haces el mínimo
dios aquí en lugar de elegir una carrera
profesional
elijas un problema pero un problema
desconocido mucho más grande que tú
e intentar resolución imagínate qué
diferente sería si en lugar de hacer la
típica pregunta de hoy y tú qué
estudiaste preguntáramos oye y tú qué
problema intentar resolver
que me respondería hoy
y si puede ir más allá de lo que te
corresponde
pues de miedo
pero vas a seguir poniendo excusas
o vas a actuar
[Aplausos]